alors c'est un moment très important et
c'est un moment de rencontre
attendu avec les deux responsables des
deux mouvements politiques qui forment
avec nous la
majorité euh c'est un moment amical
j'emploie le mot au sens le plus exa
possible parce que d'habitude l'amitié
en politique est une valeur
qu'on qu'on
voque sans être toujours absolument sûr
euh qu'on la respecte ou qu'elle
inspire le le fond de notre euh
réflexion ou de ou de nos affection mais
euh je veux dire simplement pour un
témoignage j'ai pas l'habitude de dire
le contraire de ce que je pense que avec
les deux responsables que nous allons
accueillir maintenant Stéphane séjourné
pour Renaissance que vous pouvez
[Applaudissements]
applaudir et Édouard Philippe comme
ancien chef de la majorité et
responsable et président de
[Applaudissements]
horizon nous avons des relations qui
répondent à une exigence de confiance et
de sincérité dont je peux dire que
en tout cas moi je la ressens comme
comme authentique comme réelle
euh et et que c'est nous nous parlons
chaque semaine au moins et souvent
plusieurs fois par semaine et cet
équilibre que nous avons atteint est un
équilibre précieux j'ajoute que euh tout
à l'heure toute cet après-midi est venu
partager nos notre rencontre Richard
Ferrand qui a été notre
[Applaudissements]
responsable dans tout le travail de
préparation que nous avons fait il y a
un an pour les élections législatives
Richard m'a dit qu'il devait repartir
parce que c'était l'anniversaire de son
fils je sais pas s'il est reparti ou pas
encore il est là approche-toi Richard
une seconde s'il te plaît une
seconde
[Applaudissements]
tu vas te mettre au premier
rang et je te préviens tu vas dire un
mot un mot voilà je veux dire simplement
que cette relation qui est une relation
de confiance et de sincérité euh c'est
aussi une relation et pour moi le mot a
beaucoup de sens de
corresponsabilité
euh chacun dans nos
parcours dans nos trajectoires
euh nous
avons exercé des responsabilités nous en
exerçons encore on a travaillé dans la
dans la première mandature du président
de la République on travaille maintenant
on a tous des amis au gouvernement que
je salue et à qui je dis notre amitié
mais nous nous sentons
coresponsable de l'avenir et c'est plus
important que tout ma vision personnelle
personne n obligé de la partager est
encore plus large que ça moi je crois
que nous sommes coresponsables de
l'avenir quel que soit notre engagement
c'est-à-dire pour moi
identiquement engagement politique
engagement syndical engagement
professionnel engagement dans les
communautés de pensé nous sommes
coresponsables de l'avenir même si nous
sommes en desésaccord entre nous mais à
forciorie bien sûr davantage encore
coresponsable puisque nous sommes
ensemble le la garantie de de la bonne
entente à l'intérieur de la majorité
est-ce que je puis rappeler simplement
pour ceux qui s'intéressent à la vie
politique que n'est pas
souvent que les formations politiques
qui forment une majorité s'entendent
entre elles c'est pas arrivé souvent
dans l'histoire et j'ai même des
souvenirs assez
précis d'époque un peu antérieur dans
lesquels cette amitié était doublée de
comment
dirais-je d'une compétition virile et
pas totalement correcte comme on dit
puisque c'est la Coupe du monde de rugby
donc je suis très heureux de vous dire
d'attester au fond devant vous que ça
n'est pas le cas de cette majorité ça
veut pas dire que nous sommes semblables
en tout ça veut pas dire que nous avons
surtout exactement les mêmes intuitions
les mêmes idées qu'il arrive assez
souvent même que nous puissions être
différents mais nous ne faisons pas de
nos différences une opposition
systématique et nous ne faisons pas de
nos différences une raison pour prendre
un avantage sur les autres pour enfoncer
les autres et se et se propulser
soi-même c'est un climat qui moi que je
trouve
moi de qualité humaine et civique et au
fond dans une maison comme celle-ci pour
qui la démocratie ça compte et pour qui
le civisme ça compte c'est une raison de
plus de les accueillir à avec plaisir et
chaleur et
[Applaudissements]
reconnaissance alors je vais quoi qu'il
m'it indiqué qu'il n'était absolument
pas question qu'il parle qui venait ici
par
amitié ben je vais lui dire que l'amitié
ça se prolonge et je donne la parole
pour les quelques minutes qu'il souhaite
à Richard Ferrand en
[Applaudissements]
disant en disant combien nous sommes
nombreux à regretter qu'il ne qu'il ne
puisse plus
exercer euh sa vigilance et son talent
et
sa son esprit de de responsabilité au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale et je suis
donc content de suppler cette absence en
lui donnant la
parole